foreign
good how are you good man
life going okay
uh been better but it's going all right
so what's up dude
uh so I
am having issues with my family uh I put
up some boundaries with them tried to be
as clear as possible because it seemed
like they're
respecting them and I'm kind of at the
point where I'm wondering if it's a
relationship I should cut out of my life
oh man
so tell me about it
how old are you how old are you uh I'm
35. wow okay 35. all right so tell me
about it
yeah so uh growing up kind of like
turbulent household uh older brother has
some behavioral issues like uh um a
diagnosed behavioral issue issues uh
family did the best they could uh
definitely kind of work had some impact
on me with like cops being called the
house constantly
um yelling kind of like a turbulent
household uh fast forward College the
house took a little bit of a breather
from everybody and realized that it
wasn't really a healthy environment
where everybody was come leaning on me
to be the normal grounding mechanism and
I was the child it was the youngest
person in the house like good margin
um and I need to kind of like not take
that weight on uh and fast forward to
mid 30s now and
older brother has a kid uh kind of in
this weird co-parity relationship with
my parents same turbulent activity but
with a child that I kind of see myself
in
and I've asked them to kind of like
leave me out of that relationship like I
just I can't be their their therapist to
talk about how
my brother treats my parents my parents
treat my brother
and also kind of seeing like the same
trauma being impacted on a child that I
experienced as a kid gotcha
so in the nerd world we call it
triangulation sounds like you're getting
brought in as
you're being used by the other two
parties as a as fuel to the fire that
they're casting at the other party right
so your parents call you to tell you
about what your brother's doing your
brother calls you and tells you what
your parents are doing and the whole
time you're watching this little child
just thinking just get at it run run run
run run right
yeah and the same behavioral issues from
when I was a kid so it's like oh they're
screaming in the house and they're
fighting over
so how does this how does this impact
you
you said you put up some boundaries in
in your families violating them what
does that mean
so for me it's like hey I can't be your
therapist I don't want to have every
conversation we have be about this
and
when every time that we get together
it's oh why can't you be more involved
with us as a family as well because it's
toxic and I don't really want to go back
to where I was when I was 12. right
uh are you married do you have kids
oh no okay
um
I guess the question I want to ask you
man if we were just if we were sitting
there in San Antonio sharing a meal I I
would I would
just want to know at 35 why are you
still letting your parents have any
influence in your life whatsoever at all
uh it's more either I have a
relationship with them or don't and it's
accept that accept that
you've been propping up their most them
emotionally for your whole life
and so they don't want a relationship
with you
they want to extract and use you
and so it's not you that's giving up
this relationship it's you that keeps
going into this predatory
they're trying to take your soul like a
Harry Potter dementor
it's just not a matter of of keeping up
the relationship they have they they
have ended that part
what you have to decide is do I want to
keep showing up in some sort of facade
and some sort of Mirage where we're all
in the same room together even though
I'm not even here because my 12 year old
self recognizes this toxicity and he's
were you just disassociated we checked
out
and then I gotta roll my eyes when Dad
starts complaining about brother and
then I gotta stare at the floor and
brother starts complaining about Mom you
see what I'm saying this isn't a
relationship
then I guess like the second question is
like how do I kind of come to terms with
like
you can let him go about it really what
I would hope for it really really hurts
it really really hurts
because it shouldn't be like this
it shouldn't have been like this for a
long long time
and my guess is that you've got a level
of exhaustion running underneath your
machine
because you've been trying to keep this
thing held together for your whole life
and 12 year olds think they can do it by
the time they get to be 35 they realize
they can't but they try anyway
have you sat down in this that this
thing's over
yeah I think I've been kind of like
boarding it in a way for the past like
here or so yeah
here's the two big things you got to do
the first thing is
you have to
take care of that little boy it's still
working
and you've heard me say this on the show
a million times and I'll say it a
million more
that little 12 year old boy that is
still asking the question at the age of
35.
why won't you just be my dad
why won't you just be my mom
like why do I have to do jump through so
many hoops and do so much work
for y'all to love me
and that kid's
the kid's exhausted
and that's not his job
and so you're gonna have to at some
point whether it's
you get with a therapist and go on a
rabbit hole with Bodywork and all that
kind of stuff or you sit down and for
the next
I don't know 90 days once a week you
write that kid a letter
just say dear 12 year old Carlos
remember that time
fill in the blank
and then brother came home high and dad
hit me hit you that wasn't your fault
that's cause dad
didn't know what he was doing with
brother and brother was out of control
and I'm so sorry that no one would there
to protect you
in the next week dear Carlos remember
that time
I just want you to know
when you become 35 things are going to
be different
and that's the first part of this thing
the second part of this thing I think is
equally if not more challenging
is you're going to have to find new
adult relationships to plug into because
you cannot do Life by yourself
and that's the worst man
are you a pretty lonely guy
uh no I've got a pretty strong friend
group but like chosen family there you
go
um I would even suggest marking that
some sort of event when I say event I
don't mean like renting out a stadium or
something at the Alamodome but I mean
like
having people over and saying like
henceforth y'all are my family
and looking people in the eye and saying
I'm gonna call you at 2AM when things
get sideways and when I start dating
somebody I'm gonna call you and when I
get scared about my future I'm gonna
call you right just just go around the
room but you'll have something that you
can go back and Mark as the moment
um what's your biggest fear about
just stop and return phone calls
can you objectively see they left you
yeah yeah
and just how unhealthy it's been yeah
for whatever it's worth Carlos you're
worth
your Earth relationships that you can
pour into
and there's not a bunch of holes in the
bottom of the pitcher and you're worth
relationships that people pour into you
and they don't use you
to prop themselves up but they are with
you because you're they're your friend
but all this angst man how about this
what if you just tried it in a graduated
way
you said hey once a month I'm I'm only
gonna swing by once a month I'm gonna
stay for 30 minutes
by the way let me Circle back real quick
some of your boundaries like hey I've
told them I don't want to talk about
them all the time I don't talk about
brother all the time or I don't want to
talk always be talking about Mom and Dad
make your boundaries a little more firm
I will not discuss my brother with you
period when you choose to start talking
about brother I am going to choose to
walk out of the room because you are
telling me you no longer want me in here
by bringing that up
Hey Brother
I refuse to talk about mom and dad with
you anymore I love you we can talk about
you know whatever Sports we're hanging
out whatever I'm not I refuse to talk
about this with you 100 so every time
you bring up Mom and Dad
that's like you saying hey get out of
here Carlos I don't want to talk to you
so
there's that uh make those boundaries
super firm but I would slowly start
um not even slowly I would rather
abruptly start pulling this thing apart
instead of going over there every week
I'm gonna go over once a month and
they're gonna give you the oh you too
good why aren't you coming over anymore
we miss you why aren't you over here
yeah I'm gonna I was hanging out with my
buddies I've got some stuff at work to
do I don't want to be a part of all this
drama and Chaos um because y'all are
y'all are choosing it to be like this
and I'm choosing to not be in this mess
those conversations will be hard and
make no mistake when you have true firms
strong boundaries
people will start trying to smash them
just to knock him down because they're
an affront to other people
um hold firm
hold firm little 12 year old Carlos has
been waiting for this moment for a long
time
and now it's time for 35 year old Carlos
to let that boy go run and play
he's been being adult for way too long
let him go
and it's time for you 35 year old Carlos
to say
what am I gonna do now
what am I gonna do next